welcome to this video plane why can I
not do this Wow Grande pasta
irresponsible you had some other window
open irresponsible
let's check has no name in there British
Indian Ocean Territory so could be
anybody
obviously fake so let's see the perk
defense okay it's going for quick play
on the queenside
okay let's think about it just for one
moment looks it looks really weakening
for black I mean I can just take before
in in case of recapture with the pawn
queen cakes I mean just not look right
and you know I can just take this pawn
now if I want yeah I mean it's really
just a pawn
there's no reason not to take it and
he's moving this piece again hmm okay
let's think about it yeah okay but okay
if I take it my night here on g1 is not
not in flame
how do i coordinate iam sure I can just
do this if I want it wind yet another
pawn yeah
maybe do that maybe I should just do
that it's not so much about the pawn but
it'sit's about getting getting getting
this pawn of the board so that I can can
develop my knight
okay so he can take it there but as
mentioned I want I want a quick
development Ruby - I just play Knight f3
I think is Bishop d7 which I ignored I
came anyway
Knight a three-year must be right
so one D five there's a check coming not
good so I have to move the Queen
somewhere let's check on a five also
possible yeah pull him yeah he has some
slight compensation for the pawn
quite quite amazingly okay so let's see
how to do that Knight f4 95 I have to
exploit my development let's do this on
aged six I'm just taking you 7 here for
an attack 95 f6 is not really something
he wants to play the pin so he did this
Jame Queenie forum there is no tactic
here let's just pin support the poem
no midnight my night is I don't have a
stable position for this piece which is
a problem a rupee form have to pay
attention now I didn't play this didn't
play this well not at all
dad's disappointing after this really
bad opening my black but I played I
played badly quite obviously he really
shouldn't have a position but the answer
my knight has no stable square f3 is so
somewhat stay with square but hard to
get you
protecting nc3 and trying to prevent f3
yeah I thought might be fire but why is
this not working background issues on 27
hasta 27 time warning yeah yes Queenie's
happened for the background gets all
based on little tricks and this is a
blundered III really have totally lost
the threat and so after he's basically
losing in the opening I really that's
really really bad I mean here white is a
porn up yeah and I have a huge
development advantage so I'm just
winning but I have to be precise and I
wasn't okay this this was probably a bad
idea
this this thing getting getting the porn
93 is better yeah once you see it it's
really easier I'm just going here and
this is this is also gone yeah yeah this
is just totally lost we should do 792
long castles and black is getting killed
him
he has no development and is a pawn down
so okay now that sets really bad so I
had this idea but he really now is back
in the game there should be 7s coming
and this is a very useful temple yeah I
was thinking so much for this this is
just good for white
yeah okay that this this is this is
check easy and I had the idea with 9f
forward
I didn't yeah this chance is just just
good for white he has to play this check
and now he's just a pawn down for for
not much check the same position as in
the game but without the f5 pawn and and
I'm much quicker I'm yeah so I totally
plateless like a [ __ ] and he especially
yeah this is a this is a misjudgment I
thought that with the D pawn I have
chances but this is really a bad
position it's just like the dispersed
PCM is a problem I have no stable square
for the night and he has this this
strong Bishop and here he he can take
this is simply winning to black yeah it
was just technically more alert I mean
he played the opening like I mean no
words but he played well afterwards okay
thanks for watching